comédienne écrivain militante politique
simone signoret est décédé aujourd'hui
des suites d'un cancer à l'âge de 64 ans
nous évoquerons les différents aspects
de sa carrière dans ce journal avec un
invité claude brasse à beyrouth pour la
première fois quatre diplomates se dit
victime d'un enlèvement qui n'a pas
encore été revendiqué ce mets des sept
grands pays industrialisés occidentaux
une proposition américaine avant le
sommet reggane gorbatchev genève journée
nationale d'action de 24 le 24 octobre
la cgt fait le pari de mobiliser les
salariés français voilà monsieur bonsoir
la nostalgie n'est plus ce qu'elle était
c'est le titre que simone signoret avait
choisi pour écrire le livre de sa vie
le chagrin et la tristesse de ses amis
et au delà de beaucoup de français à
annonce de sa mort sont eux en revanche
bien réel
simone signoret est morte ce matin à
l'âge de 64 ans des suites d'un cancer
elle fut à la fois une grande actrice de
cinéma de théâtre et de télévision
depuis quelques années un véritable
écrivain est depuis longtemps une
militante politique d'abord engagé aux
côtés du parti communiste puisant lutte
contre tous les pouvoirs totalitaires et
les injustices
elle était aussi et peut être avant tout
pour elle la compagne d'yves montand
c'est dans sa maison de campagne de leur
que simone signoret s'est éteinte ce
matin à 7h30
reportage de nos envoyés spéciaux sylvie
marion et il bat à auteuil dans l'eure
la maison des jours heureux est en deuil
yves montand est arrivé en fin d'après
midi vraisemblablement dissimulée dans
une voiture
personne ne l'a vu entrer un peu plus
tard le fourgon mortuaire à pénétrer la
mise en et l'intendant à fermer le
portail gardé par les gendarmes
puis ce matin toute la journée la maison
était calme trop calme très peu de
visites
nadine trintignant françois périer
patrice chéreau tous tristes le visage
fermé
seul georges cravenne tenait à se
rappeler les jours heureux pour moi
simone c'est quelqu'un que j'ai fondée
en 1938
j'étais à la terrasse du flore et j'ai
vu arriver une fille j'étais pétrifiée
d'admiration il était extraordinaire
avec un béret un trench coat
je crois même que c'est de là qu'est
partie la mode du béret du trench-coat
pour les femmes et elle était
extraordinairement d'elle ck auteuil que
simone signoret depuis plus de 20 ans
venu se reposer entre deux films
progressivement elle se mit à y vivre
presque toute l'année
c'est ici qu'elle a écrit ses livres
dans le village tout le monde
admiré et respecté simone signoret qui
avec yves montand avait ouvert sa
piscine et ses courts de tennis aux
enfants
c'est vrai qu'elle a construit une
piscine pour les mêmes vif arrive à nous
oublier
alors tous les enfants du village
avaient le droit de les voir ce que vous
avez vu ce film
ah oui je l'aimé bien comme actrice oui
très
comme actrice et puis autrement c'est
c'était une charmante très gentils ici à
auteuil on ne crains qu'une chose c'est
qu'il monte en en disant adieu simone de
main au père lachaise nous disent aussi
adieu définitivement à auteuil le
village des jours heureux
quarante années de carrière est
interrompue simone signoret venait de
terminer une série pour la troisième
chaîne de télévision française c'était
la preuve que son succès était resté
constant auprès du public
preuve également qu'elle n'a jamais
négligé ni mépriser aucune forme de son
art car on l'a vu partout
cinéma théâtre mais aussi télévision 40
ans de carrière c'est la preuve enfin
qu'elle a consacrées entièrement sa vie
à son métier jusqu'à sa dernière
extrémité pense roche
quand je finis un film je pleure me dit
alain jour c'est comme kit est une
famille
mais simone n'était pas comme les
actrices qui ne vivent que sous les
lumières en tournant et deviennent
dépressifs ou trop agitée entre deux
rôles ces familles des films été
remplacée par une autre
les amis fidèles avec lesquels elle
était à la fois élèves et conseillère
maternelle et dépendantes mais j'ai pas
beaucoup g
six ou sept regard de gens qui savent
pas qu'ils me regardent et moi je pour
moi il me regarde qui me regardent quand
je fais des choses pas bien et
kim surveille quand tu hésites et qui me
regarde en souriant quand j'ai fait des
choses bien
parmi ces regards ce de sa fille
catherine allégret et de son mari yves
montand mais aussi les regards de cette
famille plus large celle qui dans le
monde appelle à l'aide et qu'elle
écoutait car simon était la femme de
toutes les croisades
qu'est ce qui vous fait peur
brutalité d'un mauvais soir
le
le fascisme sous toutes ses formes le
totalitarisme
elle naquit simone kaminker à wiesbaden
en 1921 d'un père traducteur et d'une
mère comme toutes les autres élevé à
neuilly dans une école pour jeunes
filles élégantes elles se retrouvent à
19 ans dactylo dans un journal
collaborateurs grâce à une amie d'école
elle en part très vite pour devenir
figurante sa carrière part de la base
dans le prince charmant regarder elle a
un peu plus de 20 ans comment allez-vous
rentrer chez elle moins de dix ans plus
tard elle est après d'aidé d'anvers ou
manège d'un casque d'or une des stars
françaises les plus demandés et elle
sait choisir ses rôles au bout de 45 ans
de carrière elle a accumulé les prix de
l'oscar aux césars de ceux de londres à
ceux de cannes s'en empare être ému plus
d'un juge au lieu de se reposer sur ses
lauriers
elle s'est mis sur le tard humblement à
écrire en traduisant une pièce
américaine
le succès de ses mémoires l'amène à son
premier roman adieu volodia qu'elle
rédige admis aveugle il a fallu qu'elle
meure pour qu'on s'aperçoive qu'elle
était une actrice comme on n'en avait
jamais connu
au lieu de dire regardez moi cette
pudique avait choisi de passionnément
regarder les autres
parmi tous ses amis ce soir avec nous en
direct claude brasseur que l'on peut
considérer d'une certaine façon lui
comme un véritable membre de la famille
signoret que le brasseur en effet je
crois que simone signoret se trouvait
sur votre berceau
elle était l'amie intime de vos parents
essaient s'est penché sur votre berceau
à sa naissance
effectivement c c'est comme ça que j'ai
connus simone qui était un ami intime
de mes parents mais il ya toujours eu
entre simone et monte en émoi une
complicité un peu à terme elle il
adorait mon père et puis enfin je projet
j'ai eu l'impression ce matin qu'on
entend dans cette nouvelle qu'on avait
on avait arraché un petit bout de d'une
photo souvenir
bonjour avant tout à dire que ce soit je
pense à catherine et un montant et jeudi
montrent pas exprès parce que les
intimes sauf que dans l'intimité nos
mains appelé son mari mon temps et je
crois que c'était chez elle une preuve
d'humour et de respect
claude vous m'aviez dit tout à l'heure
au téléphone lorsque je vous ai
contactés pour accepté notre invitation
de ce soir que simone signoret n'avait
jamais renier aucun de ses engagements
qu'ils soient ceux du cinéma du théâtre
de la télévision et même de la politique
elle a toujours tenu parole
elle n'a jamais prises et méprisé aucune
forme de l'art cinématographique et
théâtrale mais je trouve que c'est un
exemple extraordinaire que cette femme
parce que cette femme qui a été une des
plus grandes stars du monde on faisait
tout à l'heure
allusion à l'osq à bollywood c'est une
des seules actrices françaises ne jamais
avoir négligé aucune des trois
disciplines qui font notre métier cinéma
théâtre et télévision et je trouve que
venant de sa part ça devrait servira
d'exemple à beaucoup de jeunes comédiens
qui justement méprise ces trois
disciplines et je trouve qu'une fois
plus simone dans ce domaine un donner
l'exemple
vous avez été une fois au moins là par
le partenaire de simone signoret qu'elle
qu'elle était qu'elle est elle sûre sur
scène sur les lieux de tournage on dit
c'est une grande actrice mais sur les
lieux de tournage et est elle une grande
actrice très telle qu'on imagine c'était
une grande actrice quand elle jouait la
comédie comme tous les grands acteurs
sur les lieux de tournage c'était une
femme c'était une femme passionnante
c'était une femme ayant avec elle j'ai
eue elle a joué ma mère dans mon passage
de dire que que nos rapports une tous
nos rapports passées nous ont
nous on est des dents enfin pour
interpréter ce seront mes dans la vie
entre deux prises
elle redevenait simone signoret avec sa
façon de conter des histoires sa façon
d'évoquer les souvenirs et évidemment
quand il évoquait les souvenirs
concernant nos familles comme il ne sait
pas ce métier d'autant plus émouvant si
vous aviez claude brasseur pour terminer
un trait de caractère principal à
retenir de simone signoret c'était quoi
c'était la générosité la chaleur humaine
la gentillesse l'engagement politique le
militantisme ce niveau du dernier gros
plans qu'on vient de voir d'âge crois
que c'est ce merveilleux regard qu'elle
avait
merci claude je le disais tout à l'heure
en ouvrant ce journal simone signoret
était à la fois une actrice un écrivain
et parallèlement à cela une militante
peut l'être politique très engagé dans
un premier temps auprès du parti
communiste puis ensuite après les
révélations sur le régime stalinien et
encore après l'invasion de la
tchécoslovaquie en 68
elle était en lutte contre tous les
régimes totalitaires et d'une manière
générale contre toutes les injustices
elle disait d'elle même ma maison est
devenue le bureau des objets trouvés de
l'injustice hervé brusini quelques
photos quelques dates la vie d'une femme
la vie d'un couple
ce jour-là en 1921 tous les deux
s'appliquer comme des écoliers de
signatures pour consacrer leur mariage
mais c'est aussi les débuts d'une autre
union politique celle-là
un engagement qu'elle ait duré plus de
trente ans d'abord aux côtés d'autres
artistes comme picasso
le couple est comme on dit compagnon de
route du parti communiste contre la
guerre d'algérie contre toutes les
guerres coloniales 1956 les voici à
moscou crispés mal à l'aise les
soviétiques viennent d'intervenir à
budapest signerai mon temps vont
littéralement s'expliquer avec nikita
khrouchtchev lors d'un souper mémorable
ça n'était pas facile de venir chez vous
en ce moment lens ignorait en début de
repas et puis c'est la rupture le
déchirement à présent aux côtés de
sartre signerait de toutes les
manifestations de toutes les pétitions
de tous les combats face au
totalitarisme d'où qu'ils viennent pour
la liberté des espagnols des afghans des
vietnamiens des hongrois et des tchèques
comme ici c'est l'aveu en 1970 signoret
montant joue le rôle des époux londres
qu'est ce que ça signifie voilà nous
avons l'ordre de perquisitionner ont
perquisitionné moi j'ai une ligne
directe avec le comité central et en
bien ce qu'il a à dire
j'ai un manga
pas besoin de mandat signoret la
comédienne rejoint signoret la rebelle
seul mot d'ordre revendiqué par cette
femme
la vigilance cette acuité politique qui
dénonce toute atteinte aux droits de
l'homme en profitant de toutes les
occasions
en fait la raison profonde de cet
engagement de toute une vie se trouve
peut-être là dans ses yeux
l'émotion il est tout entière et peu
importe finalement de savoir de quoi
parler ce jour là madame signoret c'est
effrayant ce que j'ai vu hier soir c'est
effrayant et beau sourire de ces beau
monde se ressembler en plus parce que
c'est la même ethnie fait un peu de sang
aignan je suppose il était superbe
ils étaient très contents les uns d'être
soldats réguliers les autres derrière il
est aussi question de le dire faudrait
deux heures pour dire des choses pour la
première fois à beyrouth aujourd'hui ce
ne sont pas des diplomates occidentaux
ou arabes qui ont été enlevés mais
quatre membres importants de la
représentation soviétique
le deuxième secrétaire de l'ambassade
les attaché commercial et culturel ainsi
que le médecin de la chancellerie
pour l'instant cet enlèvement n'a pas
été revendiqué mais moscou n'a fait que
confirmer la nouvelle
de beyrouth au téléphone notre envoyé
spécial patricia cost ont été kidnappés
à quelques heures d'intervalle en pleine
ville
leurs actions ont voulu frapper fort
lors de sa future a réagi en conséquence
pour ses diplomates présents à beyrouth
ont été rassemblés dans les locaux de la
chancellerie
pour éviter de nouveaux enlèvements les
explications peuvent être avancées
ces kidnappings ce n'est pas en rapport
avec l'aso actuel contre tripoli à sont
menées entre autres par le parti
communiste libanais aidé par la syrie
proche de l'union soviétique
deuxième hypothèse les intégristes
musulmans on voulait frapper ce qu'ils
considèrent comme le deuxième grand
satan après les américains soient les
russes on se demande maintenant si la
syrie que beaucoup y pensent ne va pas
être amenés à intervenir une bonne fois
pour toutes auprès des ravisseurs et pas
seulement pour les quatre ce déclic
les résultats définitifs des élections
régionales en nouvelle calédonie montre
s'il en était besoin
l'ambiguïté et la complexité de la
situation dans ce territoire en effet ce
soir les deux camps peuvent se targuer
d'une victoire puisque les
indépendantistes avec 35 18 % des
suffrages font leur entrée officielle
dans la vie politique avec le contrôle
de trois des quatre régions nouvellement
créé et puis de l'autre côté les anti
indépendantistes qui recueille 62 84 %
des voix mais le contrôle d'une seule
région celle de nouméa peuvent aussi
affirmé qu'en cas d'auto détermination
le territoire aurait prouvé son
attachement à la france la situation est
calme en nouvelle calédonie au lendemain
du vote
et l'on attend maintenant donc de savoir
exactement ce que recouvre ce nouvel
échiquier politique
quelles seront exactement les pouvoirs
et la volonté des uns et des autres
notamment des indépendantistes dans les
régions qu'ils vont contrôler reportage
de nos envoyés spéciaux
patricia charnley alain voici le nouvel
héros des indépendantistes
l'homme qui a battu 10 q qu'est ou et
dans le centre
léopold j'aurais dié à 37 ans marié père
de six enfants il travaillait comme
conducteur d'engins dans les mines de
thio avant d'entrer en politique il y a
huit ans responsable aujourd'hui de la
sécurité dans son parti il devrait être
élu président de la région centre
patry les éleveurs et agriculteurs
européens
justement sa priorité c'est la question
des terres nous pensons qu'il faut
discuter il faut discuter il faut
négocier il faut voir comment on peut
répartir les terres par rapport aux
besoins
l'école qu'on avait même été
propriétaire la terre doit servir
nouilhan les hommes celui dont il a
besoin au lieu d'emprunter donc vous
pensez nationaliser l'ensemble des miens
mais terre c'est les terres des kanaks
bon chez nous on a toujours discuté on
discute donc bon si on en détruit des
maisons où on en détruit des choses
c'est parce qu'on n'a pas discuté
donc maintenant on peut chez nous on est
quand même quand on a fait quelque chose
de mal
par rapport à nos voisins ont fait un
tabac en fait ce qu'on appelle la poutre
avant lui dire quand on l'attend on
s'excuse d'avoir fait ça y est que
maintenant on va reconstruire aux
pressions le coach didier est le symbole
des nouveaux leaders indépendantistes
reste qu'ils sont très peu nombreux il
reconnaît lui même que le fln kate
manque de cadres et qu'il doit améliorer
très vite la formation de ces futurs
animateurs
quelles seront donc les pouvoirs et les
volonté réelle de ces nouveaux
conseillers régionaux on est encore un
peu dans le flou car on attend
parallèlement la sortie des ordonnances
préparé par le ministre monsieur pisani
qui ce matin sur antenne 2 déclarait
qu'elle avait pour objet de changer la
vie quotidienne des calédoniens
notamment de ceux qui habitent en beauce
c'est à dire les propriétaires terriens
en attendant d'autres éclaircissements
les explications de pascal guinée à
nouveau statut nouvelle répartition des
pouvoirs
trois centres de décision médine égale
importance les régions d'abord le
congrès du territoire
enfin le haut commissaire de la
république quatre régions donc dont 3
acquise aux partisans de l'indépendance
chaque président de conseil dispose de
pouvoirs étendus et d'une large
autonomie
il gère le budget régional a la haute
main sur l'enseignement primaire négocié
la carte scolaire et surtout la prise en
compte des langues locales
autre compétence la redistribution des
terres ce sont les conseillers de région
qui régleront désormais les litiges
entre bruce a et tribus mélanésiennes
une prérogative crucial qui pourrait
créer des conflits avec les
propriétaires caldoches le congrès du
territoire lui est à majorité anti
indépendantistes
formé par la réunion des quatre conseils
régionaux il siège à nouméa fief du rpcr
l'assemblée dominée par les partisans de
la nouvelle calédonie française
représente le pouvoir législatif de
lille mais à pouvoir délibératif plus
apparent que réelle enfin un exécutif
puissant incarné par le haut-commissaire
de la république
il prépare et exécute les délibérations
du congrès et peut même surseoir à
certaines de ses décisions
en outre il a toute autorité sur les
services publics de l'île représentant
de l'état en nouvelle calédonie sorte de
super préfet d'avant la décentralisation
le haut commissaire aura fort à faire à
lui notamment d'arbitrer entre les
intérêts de nouméa la blanche et ceux
des trois régions gouvernées par le fln
ks et pour clore le sujet ce soir
communiqué de monsieur jacques chirac le
président du rpr qui n'est pas surpris
de ces résultats
il indique que deux tiers des habitants
se sont déclarés en faveur du maintien
de la nouvelle calédonie dans la
république française et il ajouté c'est
important si l'opposition gagne en 1986
les élections législatives et bien il y
aura tout de suite un scrutin
d'autodétermination en nouvelle
calédonie suivi d'un nouveau statut
donnant une large autonomie aux
territoires
et il conclut en déclarant les
calédoniens venant de se prononcer comme
ils l'ont fait doivent savoir que la
france ne les abandonnera pas les
syndicats de cheminots cgt cfdt et
autonome ont déclenché une grève
surprise dans les départements de l'ain
du rhône de la savoie de la haute savoie
et de l'isère mouvement largement suivi
par les cheminots qui n'accepte pas les
décisions prises par la direction sncf
les obligeant après les accidents de
l'été à une révision générale de leurs
connaissances dans ces régions le trafic
est sérieusement perturbé la cgt vient
de lancer un appel à une journée
nationale d'action marquée par des
grèves et des manifestations le 24
octobre prochain
un mouvement de grande ampleur
préconisée par ce syndicat qui depuis
l'essai depuis l'été pardon essaie de
faire monter la pression des
revendications ouvrières le pourquoi de
cette journée louis viannet numéro deux
de la cgt dans tous les domaines
nous assistons à une accélération de la
dégradation de la situation
au niveau de l'emploi j'insiste pas mais
ce que je peux dire c'est que à une
situation déjà particulièrement
alarmante chaque jour amène son cortège
de décision de cases de licenciement de
suppressions d'emplois autrement dit on
on va vers on va vers une situation
encore plus dégradée où nous proposons
de faire de cette journée pour toutes
les catégories une grande journée de
lutte avec beaucoup de grève avec des
manifestations massives dans tout le
pays pour que la voix du mécontentement
se transforme en exigence et et nous
considérons que beaucoup beaucoup de
choses peuvent être faites pour aller
dans le sens de la réalisation d'une
journée qui va compter un grand sens
bien quand on se rend bien compte en
décidant cette journée la cgt fait un
pari sur la combativité des salariés
français et de ses propres troupes
j'ai rarement si j'étais prend un risque
elle sait que ses militants et ses
adhérents sont moins nombreux elle sait
que les salariés sont difficiles à
mobiliser
elle lance cependant une journée
nationale d'action avec des grèves car
elle s'est engagée dans un processus
pratiquement irréversibles au début de
l'année c'était le coup de semonce la
grève générale était envisagé au
printemps
rien ne venait pendant l'été c'étaient
les coups de poing et les coups de pub
avec les opérations et skf renault et
chantiers navals à dunkerque à l'automne
c'est le coup de gong
avant la dernière manche celle qui
précède le 42e congrès cgt est plus loin
des élections législatives la cgt
attaque de front le patronat mais aussi
le gouvernement les socialistes du
syndicat ont du mal à suivre cette
marche
le débat est vif c'est pourquoi la
centrale que dirige henri krasucki et
louis viannet se donnent plus de trois
semaines pour préparer cette difficile
mobilisation à la veille du voyage de
monsieur gorbatchev en france dans une
interview au journal le figaro le
président reagan déclare que le numéro
un soviétique pour être pourra ainsi
tester l'unité du camp occidental et
pour rassurer ses alliés monsieur
reggane ajoute notre programme de
défense spatial ne remet pas en cause
l'engagement des états unis auprès de
ses partenaires européens et les états
unis proposent parallèlement une réunion
des sept grands pays occidentaux
industrialisés
avant la rencontre à genève entre ronald
regan et michael gorbatchev
de washington notre correspondant chaka
bouche on ne compte plus les débats et
les déclarations officielles du côté
américain sur le prochain sommet reagan
gorbatchev en novembre à genève la
future rencontre des deux super grand et
cliffs en partie mais en partie
seulement
l'arrivée à paris du numéro un
soviétique les responsables américains
sont venus à plusieurs reprises sur le
fait que cette visite en france de
monsieur gorbatchev est une première
pour le leader soviétique en occident
depuis son installation au kremlin
washington va donc suivre à la loupe le
déroulement des entretiens de paris avec
une attention spéciale pour les
commentaires qui porteront sur le projet
américain de guerre des étoiles en
raison des réticences de la france et de
l'hostilité ouverte de l'urss en ald
reggane ne perd jamais une occasion de
louer la fermeté de françois mitterrand
à l'égard de moscou
et d'insister sur la solidarité des
occidentaux face au monde communiste
dans cet esprit il aurait proposé selon
une source japonaise
un sommet extraordinaire des sept
principaux pays industriels dont la
france avant sa rencontre avec
gorbatchev bessette se réunir et le 24
octobre à new york à l'occasion du 40ème
anniversaire des nations unies le
président égyptien monsieur moubarak
était aujourd'hui en visite à paris où
il a rencontré le président de
république monsieur françois mitterrand
l'essentiel de la discussion a porté sur
les problèmes du proche orient il y a
espoir de paix en 86 selon le chef de
l'état égyptien qui a donc rencontré ce
midi monsieur françois mitterrand les
positions s'assouplissent c'est aussi le
sentiment du président américain
monsieur reggane recevant le roi hussein
de jordanie le souverain s'étant
déclarée la semaine dernière aux nations
unies prêt à négocier rapidement et
directement avec israël
au mexique les recherches des disparus à
peine terminée la démolition des
immeubles détruits dans la capitale à
mexico va commencer la vie reprend aussi
avec inévitablement son cortège
d'injustices et de corruption comme
l'ont constaté nos envoyés spéciaux
rachid arhab et gilles dollars ces
manifestants réclament que les
représentants de deux sociétés
nationales de gestion d'immeubles
viennent répondre devant l'assemblée
nationale à des questions sur le manque
de solidité de certaines habitations de
type à celle ici à mexico on prétend
qu'il ya beaucoup de sable et peu de
béton dans les murs la corruption
commence au niveau de petits trafics
mais elle touchera aussi des gens très
importants c'est en grande partie ainsi
parce qu'il ya une réglementation pour
toutes les constructions mais comme vous
le savez nous vivons sous l' empire de
la corruption des pots-de-vin de la mort
alors cette réglementation et violet
très souvent et ça nous ici en ce moment
nous voulons mettre l'accent non pas sur
la recherche des responsabilités nous
plutôt sur l'adoption de mesures
urgentes pour résoudre les problèmes qui
sont posés querelle politique peut-être
puisque ce député socialiste est un
ancien candidat à la présidence de la
république
mais les rares architectes qui acceptent
de parler explique aussi la mauvaise
qualité de la construction par la
spéculation immobilière autres formes de
corruption s'est traduit pas le manque
de contrôle
du calcul même delà des structures et
ensuite se traduit aussi par une
mauvaise qualité de la construction où
il n'y a pas vraiment une super vision
de chantier il n'y a pas eu une
supervision et de ce fait là il est les
bâtiments sont conçus un peu n'importe
comment et ça c'est fait c'est du non
seulement aux privés eux aussi au
gouvernement au manque de contrôle qui
lie à sur les normes et les
spécifications de du bâtiment
officiellement on dit ici se battre sans
arrêt contre la corruption d'ailleurs
beaucoup d'immeubles qui se sont
effondrés ont été construits par le
gouvernement précédent
les dirigeants actuels par l'état
présent de revoir les réglementations en
matière de construction
elle allègue la même pas que ces
règlements en vigueur prennent en compte
le fait que les bâtiments de t'avoir une
résistance aux chocs latéraux mais ces
normes sont basés sur nos expériences
antérieures n'ont que nous avons
appliqué
encore faudrait-il faire respecter une
nouvelle réglementation la précédente
datée de 1977
vingt ans auparavant le mexique avait
connu un autre tremblement de terre et
déjà la loi avait été modifiée mais la
corruption s'adapte visiblement à toutes
les situations
en france le temps de ce mois de
septembre nous inciterait presque à
repartir en vacances
en attendant si vous faites partie d un
million et demi de caravaniers français
vous pouvez toujours allez rêver quelque
part là bas au salon de la caravane qui
se tient jusqu'à dimanche prochain au
bourget dans la banlieue parisienne où
sont présentés les toutes dernières
tendances
reportage de jean pierre métivier et
jean-jacques le deuil
cette année la mode et soit au
gigantisme avec caravane à tiroirs
livrable clés en main habillage style
campagnard ou à l inverse des caravanes
cocon style bonbonnière pour deux autres
tendances du dernier salon les dépliante
s'épanouissant comme des fleurs disent
les brochures ou encore encastré dans la
voiture compromis entre caravanes et
camping-cars voire même simple remords
pour sika dépliable elle aussi un salon
de rêve pour tous ceux qui deviennent
fils du vent à l'époque des congés payés
combien sont ils
impossible de le dire avec certitude
peut-être trois millions dont certains
aiment à se retrouver chaque année au
même emplacement avec les mêmes voisins
ils ont payé 40 mille francs pour ce
rêve comme avantage une caravane
valais un jour moi puis
d'aller dans des cons
nous sommes
assez réduit quand j'irai lui une
location droit devant
m
les coupures sont dit
dans des terrains où ils ont
spécialement conçu pour des caravanes
c'est mieux que c'est dans les terres
pour a pour le confort
il y a aussi les modèles haute couture
où il serait malséant d'emporter ses
assiettes en carton un signe que le
marché se porte bien il y à un million
deux cent mille caravane en france n'en
déplaise aux esprits chagrins
les chiens aboient la caravane passe
en sport il nous faut commencer par une
triste nouvelle le décès du rugbyman de
béziers et internationales pierre lacan
qui a été victime hier d'un accident de
la route en tennis après sa victoire au
grand prix de barcelone contre le
suédois wilander le français thierry
tulasne a empoché 375 mille dollars
c'est pas mal les remontées de la 47e à
la 26e place du classement mondial des
meilleurs joueurs ce n'est pas mal non
plus le premier loto sportif nouvelle
formule a fait un heureux
un seul qui a gagné 2 millions 130 2345
francs il a trouvé les 16 bon résultat
du championnat de france de football de
première et de seconde division
il faut dire que c'était un grand
spécialiste puisque son nom on vient de
l'apprendre ce soir c'est dominique
colonna
ancien gardien de but de la grande
équipe de reims et de l'équipe de france
quant aux pronostics pour le prochain
loto sportif s'est tout de suite après
le journal pour l'instant on va prendre
connaissance des prévisions météo
alain gillot-pétré tient des nuages
ah oui ça fait longtemps qu'on n'avait
pas vu c'est pour ça que la prochaine ce
soir et grises marqué les paniers
seulement pour ça regardez l'anticyclone
toujours au dessus de nos têtes mais nos
têtes elle le voit partir vers l'est
progressivement ce qui fait que le vent
commence à s'orienter au sud-est avant
de passer au sud donc les températures
vont remonter et lire ses nuages qui
arrivent mais au fur et à mesure qu'ils
arrivent ils se désagrègent tomberiez
tout ça n'est pas très organisée donc
sur la carte de demain vous ne trouverez
sur la moitié ouest que que de très
belles éclaircies avec des passages
nuageux peut-être plus abondants sur la
bretagne tandis que sur la moitié est
après dissipation des brouillards au
nord-est et de la brume sur le golfe du
lion et bien comme aujourd'hui ce sera
du beau temps baromètre en baisse
thermomètre en hausse on se refuse
vraiment rien regarder cela va de 22 à
28 degrés sur la moitié nord 27 à paris
et de 29 à 32 degrés sur la moitié sud
32 à perpignan 32 à marseille enfin à
demain demain ce sera le mardi 1er
octobre dans ta main autrement verra
bien ce qu'il sera trois minutes de
seulement 1 paris lever 650 et une
couche et 18h31
bonne fête à toutes les terrasses et
celle de lisieux et il frappe adverse à
thaksin ans nous quitter je vous
rappelle les principaux titres de
l'actualité d'aujourd'hui tout d'abord
la mort le décès des suites d'un cancer
de l'actrice simone signoret qui était
âgé de 64 ans et puis à beyrouth pour la
première fois des diplomates soviétiques
compter
est enlevée personne n'a encore
revendiqué l'enlèvement de ces quatre
personnes le dernier journal c'est tout
à l'heure bernard pradines au premier
rendez-vous demain matin
télématin 16h45 bonsoir à demain 20
heures